how to motivate your staff so I got a
great question for one of my newsletter
readers Ozzy love you guys who wrote in
to say Thank You Evan my question is how
can I motivate my staff to do more sales
and better work many times my staff tell
me I'm slow in making decisions
I have no vision in my business my
customers target is not clear and I have
no good marketing plan you have any
great ideas are looking forward to
hearing from you this is an interesting
one
you know a-z I don't know how you think
your staff we motivated when you're not
making decisions quickly you have no
vision
you have no marketing plan you don't
know who your customer is that that's
pretty hard to get up and go to work for
a guy who doesn't have those things in
place right you don't have to have all
the answers but the big picture stop the
founder/ceo stuff you better have in
place otherwise people aren't gonna be
motivated right you got it you got to be
a leader if you look at what motivates
employees and you can look at countless
surveys and studies that have been done
what really motivates employees is not
the money it's not the benefits it's not
the free lunches but the gym it's not
the daycare that you provide
it's the feeling like they're doing work
that is meaningful and appreciate that's
what people really want and if you look
at the studies you know you give
somebody a bonus I mean for the next
week you know their productivity goes up
when they're they're hitting their
milestones and then it comes back down
because it in flatlines right and people
are not motivated by the money so people
are motivated by working out a
meaningful job something that they feel
like they're contributing to and then
they're going to work for somebody who
has no vision no business plan no you
know there's slow to make decisions how
can they expect to stay motivated what
you really need to do ozzie is take a
weekend go somewhere else and really
figure out what this business means to
you why is it so important what do you
stand for
what is this company all about
you've got to figure that out to not
only motivate your staff one of it
yourself like how are you getting up and
being motivated every day to go to work
you need to be feeling like you're doing
something important so my business is
all about believe I did you have the
shirt on I'm sick today so I'm you know
drinking my honey tea and whatever black
tea but everybody on my team has to
believe they have to like believe they
have to feel like they want to come and
work here where if you don't like
believe I'm not gonna be able to
motivate you right like I can give you
all the money in the world it's not
gonna keep you motivated because the
message is so strong and and meaningful
I have people who write in to me
constantly who are they want to
volunteer they don't want to get paid
anything they just want to be part of
the belief movement they'll write in
they say hey if you ever need that
writer if you ever need a researcher if
you ever need of whatever it is that
they offer I'm I'll do for free just let
me know I want to be part of what you're
doing that's powerful and the people on
my team love what we're all about
and I don't need to motivate them
because the work that we're doing is
motivating and everything that we put
out is motivating and believe in an
entrepreneur and so that's a start right
like what the heck do you stand for and
that's something you have to figure out
personally and then bring up to your
business and when you have that clear
sense of direction then making decisions
becomes easier then creating a marketing
plan is a lot easier that knowing who
your customers are is a lot easier and
with that clear vision in place it then
makes it so much easier to bring on the
right sales people and keep them
motivated and it may mean that your team
has to change right now that you know
what you stand for now that not
everybody on the team may be on that
same page and if they're not motivated
right now then chances are you might
need to get somebody and that's okay but
the people we attract will be ones who
how much are much better fit for your
company right if you lead what here's
what we stand for here's what we're
excited about here's the change you
trying to create in the world then
people will self select and you'll get
much better candidates coming in so that
is how you keep your staff motivated
you'll be watching you can subscribe to
the channel if you like this video and
want to see more you can support me by
clicking on the link in the description
and leave a comment let me know what you
think I love your comments they make my
day every morning to wake up but check
my comments so thank you for that and
I'll see you soon